Sarah Wagenknecht gründet eigene Partei
am Montag verkündete Sarah Wagenknecht
die Gründung eines neuen vereines
mit dem überhaupt nicht egozentrischen Namen
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht.
Dieser Verein
soll sich mit der Gründung einer neuen Partei
beschäftigen,
die irgendwas mit Wirtschaft und soziale Gerechtigkeit
zu tun haben soll.
Die Art und Weise von Sarah Wagenknecht,
Politik zu machen
und in der Öffentlichkeit aufzutreten,
führt hauptlich dazu,
was sie selber sagt, nicht,
dass die Menschen sich wieder von Politik abgeholt
fühlen. Es führt im Zweifel nur dazu,
dass die linke Szene sich spaltet
und die Gesellschaft weiterhin polarisiert.